so think about your high school class
who was a superstar in that class the
person you said might be president
United States he or she may not be that
famous now all the people who became
presidents of the United States in the
last 100 years only one of them was
probably seen as a good student or the
star at that time that was probably Bill
Clinton he was a pretty good student
that was a later became a Rhodes scholar
most of the people who become president
United States are not people that were
that famous or that well known our
current president very nice person I
know him quite well but you know he was
a you know a football player in high
school not considered to be likely
president United States his predecessor
Donald Trump probably wasn't thought to
be potential president United States
when he was younger and so on so it's
just the life life evolves that way and
you can't tell who's going to be coming
the next president United States just by
looking at their resumes when they were
in high school